[موسيقى]
وأين كان في ممر تيس
أنا أبحث عن وقت ممتاز اختاره رأسي
لنرى وقت شهود العيان
داخل استراحة قصبية vd خذ ذلك
يتبع في أن يصبح ديسمبر بعد أ
بعد الألم أو للإشارة إلى الطبيعي
الرياضية الدقيقة 15 إصابة مدمجة للغاية
اللعبة لا تعود مرة أخرى وشاهد الأديان
× المدرسة الثانوية في القصة التي لا تقل عن ثلاثة
مرات
الفريق كنت زجاجة اقتبس ماذا
عندما تزداد بشكل خاص
[موسيقى]
ماذا كان
المنفذ والفطر السحري جي
وقتي وسدادات قطني كيف نرتاح
في تلك الحلقة في بروج ويحصل
بورشات
التسريب لأحبك فقط لأن
منها
النظام يغير هذا لأنهم كانوا واحد
له الديمقراطية والحرية الحقيقية
اشخاص
الرياح iping سيئة للغاية لأنهم
أريد ثلاثة أنه كان عليه أن يأخذها ليكون دي
الأولاد هنا في الغسيل العملاق
[موسيقى]